metro is on scene after a barricade
situation in the east valley near
bonanza and lamb
we can tell you the suspect has been
safely taken into custody
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough is
live on scene with the very latest hi
madison
yeah alex the situation unfolded right
at walgreens now take a look behind me
it's right behind the panda if you're
having trouble seeing it
this is off of bonanza road and lamb
boulevard police say the business was
evacuated immediately
while we are still waiting more details
the suspect a man
barricaded himself inside of the store
it's still unclear if he had a weapon
but locals around
knew it was a bad situation when police
showed up
15 minutes later they came in and told
us to leave to exit the store
there's something really bad going on
and
i went and got my manager and had her
leave the store with me i wasn't going
to leave her
the suspect was handcuffed and taken
into custody lamb
and bonanza were closed for some time
but they have currently reopened as you
can see
traffic is moving swiftly as soon as we
learn more information we will make sure
to bring that to you
asap reporting live madison kimbrough 8
news now
all right madison thanks so much for
that report we'll check back in with you
too